for any real number X let brackets
around X denote the largest integer less
than or equal to X often known as the
greatest integer function let F be a
real valued function defined on the
interval negative 10 to 10 including the
boundaries by f of X is equal to X - the
greatest integer of X if the greatest
integer of X is odd and 1 plus the
greatest integer of X - X if the
greatest integer of X is even then the
value of pi squared over 10 times the
definite integral from negative 10 to 10
of f of X cosine PI of X DX is so before
we even try to attempt to evaluate this
integral let's see if we can at least
visualize this function f of X right
over here so let's do our best to
visualize it so let me draw my x-axis
and let me draw my y-axis so let me draw
my y-axis and then let's think about
this what this function will look like
so this is X is equal to 0 this is X is
equal to 0 this is X is equal to 1 X is
equal to 2 X is equal to 3 we could go
down to negative 1 negative 2 we could
just keep going if we like hopefully
we'll see some type of pattern because
it seems to change from odd to even so
between 0 & 1 what is the absolute sorry
what is the greatest integer of X so
between 0 & 1 so let me just write it
over here so between 0 & 1
until you get to 1 so maybe I should do
this from including 0 until 1 the
greatest integer of X the greatest
integer of X is equal to 0 if I'm at
point 5 the greatest integer below point
5 is 0 as I go from 1 to 2 as I go from
1 to 2 the greatest it this brackets
around X is equal to 1 it's the greatest
inter from it 1.5 the greatest integer
is 1 if I'm at 1.9 the greatest integer
is 1 and then if I go to above from
between 2 & 3 so if I go between 2 & 3
see then the greatest integer is going
to be 2 if I'm at 2.5 grades ginger is
going to be 2 so with that let's try to
at least draw this function over these
intervals so between 0 and 1 the
greatest integer is 0 0 we can consider
to be even 0 is even especially for
alternating 1 is odd 2 is even 3 is odd
so 0 is even so we would look at this
circumstance right over here if X is
even and then over this prime frame or
over this part of the x axis the
greatest integer of X is just 0 so the
equation in or the line or the function
is just going to be 1 minus x over this
interval because the greatest integer is
0 so 1 minus X will look like this if
this is 1 1 minus X just goes down like
that
that's what it looks like from 0 to 1
now let's think about what happens as we
go from 1 to 2 as we go from 1 to 2 or
not including 2 but including 1 all the
way up to 2 not including it the
greatest integer is 1 or the greatest
integer the greatest integer is odd
so we use this case and over here we're
going to have X minus the greatest
integer of X over this interval the
greatest integer of X is 1 so it's going
to be the graph of x minus 1 so X minus
1 at 1 is going to be 0 and at 2 it's
going to be 1 again so it's going to be
this it's going to look just like that
so this right here is X minus 1 and then
this over here essentially was 1 minus X
and we could keep doing it as we go from
2 to 3 the greatest integer of X is 2 we
would look at this case so we're going
to have 1 plus 2 so we're going to have
3 we're going to have 3 here minus X so
when we start over here when X is 2 or a
little bit above that we're gonna have 3
minus 2 we're going to go to 1 it's
going to be right at 1 and then as X is
equal to 3 3 minus 3 is 0 it's going to
oscillate back down like this so I think
we have an appreciation for what this
graph is going to look like if keep it's
going to keep going up and down like
this with the slope of negative 1 then
pause
one the negative one and positive one
it's just going to keep doing that over
and over again you can keep trying it
out with other intervals but it's pretty
clear that this is the pattern now what
is what we want to do is evaluate the
integral from 10 to negative 10 of this
function times cosine of PI of X so
let's think about cosine of PI of X and
things and think about whether that also
is periodic and of course it is and then
if we can simplify this integral so we
don't have to evaluate it over over this
entire period over here maybe we can
simplify it into a simpler integral so
cosine of PI X cosine of 0 is 0 cosine
sorry cosine of 0 is 1 I want to get
that wrong because that's just cosine PI
0 is cosine of 0 so that's 1 cosine of
PI is negative 1 so when X is equal to 1
this becomes cosine of pi so then the
value of the function is negative 1
it'll be over here and then cosine of 2
pi 2 times pi is then 1 again so it'll
look like this let me this of course
will be this is at 1/2 when you put it
over here become PI over 2 cosine of PI
over 2 is 0 0 so it'll look like this it
will look let me draw it as neatly as
possible so it will look like this
cosine and then it'll keep doing that
and then we'll go like this so it is
also periodic so if we wanted to figure
out if we wanted to figure out the the
integral of the product of these two
periodic functions from all the way from
negative 10 to 10 can we simplify that
and it looks like it would just be
because we have this interval let's look
at this interval over here let's look
let's look at just from 0 to 1 so just
from 0 to 1 we're going to take this
function and take the product of this
cosine x essentially 1 minus X and then
find the area under that curve whatever
it might be then when we go from 1 to 2
when we take the product of this and X
minus 1 it's actually going to be the
same area because these two
going from zero to one going from zero
to one and going from one to two it's
completely symmetric you could flip it
over you could flip it over this line of
symmetry and both functions are
completely are completely symmetric so
you're going to have the same area when
you take their product so what we see is
every interval over every interval when
you go from two to three it's going to
be first of all it's clearly going the
integral from two to three is clearly
the same thing as the integral from zero
to one both functions look identical
over that integral over that interval
but it'll also be the same as going from
one to two because it's completely
symmetric when you when you take the
products of the function that function
will be completely symmetric around this
axis so the integral from here to here
will be the same as the integral from
there to there so with that said we can
rewrite this thing over here so what we
want to evaluate PI squared over ten
times the integral from negative 10 to
10 of f of X cosine cosine of PI X using
the logic we just talked about this is
going to be the same thing as being
equal to PI squared over 10 PI squared
over 10 times the integral well times
the integral of from 0 to 1 but 20 times
that because we have 20 integers between
negative 10 and 10 we have 20 intervals
of length 1 so times 20 times the
integral times the integral from 0 to 1
of f of X of f of X cosine of PI X DX
forgot to write forgot to write the DX
over there and I want to make sure you
understand it because this is really the
hard part of the problem just realizing
that the integral over this interval is
just one twentieth of the whole thing
because over every interval from zero to
one it's going to be this the integral
is going to evaluate to the same thing
as going from one to two which will be
the same thing as going from two to
three we're going from negative 2 to
negative one so instead of doing the
whole interval from negative 10 to 10
we're just doing 20 times the interval
from zero to 1 from negative 10 to 10
you actually have 20 you're there's a
difference of 20 here so we're
multiplying by 20 and this simplifies it
a good bit first of all this part over
here simplifies to 20 divided by 10 is 2
so it's 2 pi squared
so becomes 2 pi squared that's just this
part over here times the integral from 0
to 1 now from 0 to 1 what is f of X well
we just figure it out from 0 to 1 f of X
is just 1 minus X f of X is just 1 minus
X from 0 to 1 times cosine of PI X
cosine of PI X DX and now we just have
to evaluate this integral right over
here so let's do that so 1 minus x times
cosine of PI X is the same thing as
cosine of PI X minus X cosine of PI X
now this right here taking the
antiderivative take the we're going to
take the well let's just focus on taking
the antiderivative this is pretty easy
but let's try to do this one because it
seems a little bit more complicated so
let's take the antiderivative of X
cosine of PI X DX and what should jump
in your mind is well you know this isn't
that simple but if I were able to take
the derivative of X that would simplify
it's very easy to take the
antiderivative cosine of PI X without
making it more complicated
so maybe integration by parts and
remember integration by parts tells us
that the integral I'll write it up here
the integral of U DV is equal to UV
minus the integral of V D U and we'll
apply that here but there's I've done
many many videos where I prove this and
show examples of exactly what that means
but let's apply it right over here and
in general we're going to take the
derivative of whatever the u thing is so
we want you to be something that's
simpler when I take the derivative and
then we're going to take the
antiderivative of DV so we want
something that does not become more
complicated when I take the
antiderivative so the thing that becomes
simpler when I take its derivative is X
so if I set u is equal to X then clearly
D U is equal to just DX or you say D u
DX is equal to 1 or so D U is equal to
DX and then DV then DV is going to be
the rest of this this whole thing over
here is going to be is going to be DV
DV is equal to is equal to cosine PI X
DX and so V would just be the
antiderivative of this with respect to X
V is going to be equal to 1 over PI 1
over PI sine of PI X right if I took the
derivative here derivative of the inside
you get 2 pi times 1 over PI cancels out
derivative of sine of PI X becomes
cosine of PI X so that's our U that's
our V so this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to u times V
so it's equal to X this x times this so
x over PI sine of pi X - minus the
integral minus the integral of V which
is 1 over PI sine of PI X D u D U is
just DX D X and this is pretty
straightforward the antiderivative of
sine of PI X is 1 over PI or negative 1
over PI cosine of PI X and you could
take the derivative if you don't believe
me you could do u substitution but
hopefully you can start to do these in
your head especially if it going to take
the ìit joint entrance exam so this
whole expression is going to be this
part over here is going to be x x over
pi sine of PI X and then this over here
is going to be well you have the
antiderivative sine of PI X is 1 over
negative 1 over PI cosine of PI X the
negatives cancel out so you have plus
and then you the 1 over pi times 1 over
PI 1 over PI squared cosine of PI X
that's the antiderivative right then you
can verify derivative of cosine of PI X
is going to be negative pi sine of X 1
pi will cancel out here you get a
negative sign then you have a sine of PI
X so this is the antiderivative of that
and so if we want the antiderivative of
this whole thing right over here this is
this is what we care about from 0 to 1
DX the antiderivative
of cosine PI X pretty straightforward
we've actually already done it right
over here it is 1 over PI 1 over PI sine
of PI X that's this first term and the
antiderivative of X cosine PI X is this
thing over here but we're subtracting it
so we'll put a negative sign out front
so minus X over PI sine of PI X minus 1
over PI squared cosine of cosine of PI X
and of course we took the antiderivative
but it's a definite integral we need to
evaluate it from 0 to 1 0 to 1 and we
don't want to figure it forget that 2 pi
squared out front that 2 pi squared out
front so let's evaluate this so the
first thing we're going to have 1 over
PI sine of 1 pi sine of 1 pi is 0 so
you've 0 minus 1 over pi times sine of 1
pi again that's again 0 minus 1 over PI
squared cosine of PI cosine or cosine of
1 PI cosine of PI is negative 1 negative
1 times negative 1 over PI squared is
plus 1 over PI squared so we've
evaluated it at 1 and from that we want
to subtract it evaluated at 0 sine of 0
is 0 minus this is clearly zero because
you have a 0 out front minus 0 and then
you have minus cosine of 0 cosine of 0
is 1 so then you have a minus 1 over PI
squared 1 over PI squared and so this
term we could just say this is a
negative these don't matter negative
positive positive and we're just left
with a 1 over PI squared plus 1 over PI
squared which is equal to which is equal
to 2 over PI squared that's what this
part evaluates to it's 2 over PI squared
but we can't forget we can't forget that
we're going to multiply this whole thing
times 2 pi squared so we're going to
multiply the whole thing times 2 pi
squared that's this thing out front here
and so the PI squared cancels out the PI
squared we're left with
two times two which is equal to four and
we're done this thing that looked pretty
complicated just evaluates out to four